let me let me pull this story we got
from timcast.com
poll finds republicans and independents
would stay and fight if america was
invaded democrats say they would flee i
know this guy and he was tweeting up a
storm during 2020 about how trump was
evil and trump was bad and you know what
he did right after the election
nothing he moved to europe
and i'm just like this dude
votes for joe biden and then within a
couple months the ship is sinking gas
prices all these problems and he's gone
and he's gone and here i am sitting here
holding the bag and i just feel like
yo these people are evil
right it's the banality of people it's
not diabolical evil it is you know what
neutral evil i guess you'd call it it is
it is different
indifference as they watch things
crumble around them they say i'm gonna
vote for biden because i want to signal
to everybody how virtuous i am but i'm
gone the moment he gets elected i'm
gonna go live somewhere else because we
know how bad it's gonna get and there
they go they go off so it's funny they
say that we flee because the same people
were like when trump had gone moving to
canada
none of them none of them did none of
them did and the funniest part is we
were living in canada at the time you
know that's rich that you all think you
can just come here
like but it's just weird american
exceptionalism where you guys think you
just go anywhere we can bill clinton
um
but uh with trump things things were
good yeah you know so so when trump got
elected these celebrities were like well
you know my 401k is doing well my bank
account's doing well i'm getting more
work i'm okay when biden hits and
everything starts going bad they're like
i'm going to get out of here because
things are falling apart and it's their
fault yeah here we are i would not say
these europe these people say the
majority of democrats that they would
flee if the u.s got attacked and that's
a crazy thought you know that these
people are helping steer the ship iran
but they have no problem admitting they
would jump overboard the sign of any any
conflict or turmoil leave us holding
that bag yeah oh i just said that
clinton fled to canada during vietnam i
think that he just sought and received
deferments to avoid combat being sent to
the jungle good job bill i don't know if
he actually went to canada well that was
different at the time canada actually
did take
uh people who wanted to not go to
vietnam i think but i if you tried to
get into canada during i'd be one worse
than gone i would you know be i'd have
both uniforms in my backpack and then
whoever was winning that particular
battle yeah there's no way i'd i would
do everything i could and not get sent
to go to the meat grinder in the jungle
there's i don't think i'd be fighting
any wars well vietnam i get but let's
like what would happen right now uh you
you find patriots if america got invaded
would you be on the front line defending
america no i'm on the front line of uh
windsor ontario yeah i'd be on the front
lines of a gender assignment surge
reassignment surgery missed out firing
my way out
you're in america now
all right you are suckling the bosom of
this country you will stand suckling the
what's the reverse of suckling the
puzzle
funding your
social people
we're being held by the ankles and just
shaking out of your mind yeah well the
taxes are higher in canada new york city
are they irs no no no no keeping your
cities higher it's not just anywhere in
canada and we don't get free health care
yeah i assure you that i'm not uh well
suckling off
you just put some i said you do and
you're telling and you're and to answer
your question yeah if uncle sam came
knocking my door they're like listen you
gotta join the battalion i'll go yeah
yeah i'll meet you there
you need a jester you're saying you
don't get health care in new york but
you do get rat kings you know to wrestle
i do know what uh i tried to write in a
rat so i did this movie remember rob
ford yeah yeah the mayor of toronto
i made this movie about rob ford i wrote
it he's a guy
he's smoking crack and i tried to write
in a rat king into the movie tell me
about this rat king thing what is that
it's uh basically it's a bunch of rats
and then their tails get all matted with
like mud and dirt and then they all get
stuck together and then they essentially
become it's like a hive mind thing where
they because you know now their tails
are all stuck together so they have to
move in unison because otherwise they're
all pulling
uh so it's yeah see they're all there
it's called the rat king and they do
they move together well they have to
otherwise how you get anywhere wow does
one of them take over is the brain i
don't know i think it's like a symbiotic
like they all
it's like a ouija board you know yeah
it's like exactly it's like a ouija
board it's like a corporation for rats
yeah yeah
this crazy dude i don't know is it is it
real though because some people have
said that it's like an urban legend oh i
guess there you go it does look man-made
rat king phenomena synthetic rat kings
tears yeah i don't i don't know there's
rats everywhere in new york that one the
medium one good left second top left
that looks real why on wikipedia does it
say historically this phenomenon is
particularly associated with germany why
does it say that in wikipedia it's in
the first paragraph on wikipedia really
yeah maybe and that's 4chan getting in
there yeah what the heck that's weird
maybe germany has rat kings i mean but
you're saying new york city
yeah maybe oh squirrels do the same
thing oh interesting squirrel king just
doesn't have a good one no yes yeah it
doesn't roll off yeah have you ever seen
a squirrel they do once they once you
put them in your rectum they get tangled
so they're not real but i was in new
york i was in central park and i saw it
was a genetic it was like a chimeric
squirrel
something happened to it where it's tail
part of it didn't have fur and part of
it didn't have like poof it was out
partly albino it's like a mange so like
no no no it was like half albino
squirrel and so it looked half rat and
half squirrel but they can't procreate
so it's not a real thing a square rat
but people think they are because
they'll see these mutant squirrels right
with like less hair on one side and they
think it's like a mutant you know like a
hybrid huh unless yeah it's just they're
ill and diseased right
no it could just be a genetic thing yeah
it's just like you know mutation yeah
yeah they're they are uh aggressive in
new york oh yeah the rats squirrels
and the homeless yeah
the squirrels i used to feed them and
they'd come up and then every once in a
while you get one that would just grab
the bag of nuts and run and and pigeons
you can hold out your hand and the
pigeons will jump on you you can walk up
to a pigeon in new york and hold that
food it'll jump into your hand and start
eating yeah they don't have any they're
not afraid like yeah
and then what you do is you grab its
feet and they can't get away and then
you you take it home mike tyson
mike tyson's gonna be sad that you said
that yeah they used to they used to do
that you know right what's that the i
think was the the was it the rock no
passenger pigeon
was it that was the extinct one yeah new
york they would like go with a net and
just catch pigeon and eat them yep
could you imagine living that way like
going out in new york and putting up a
rat trap and being like we got some meat
tonight
i mean it's crazy right that's what they
do that's the north korean camps or
whatever you know they put them in the
labor camps that's a delicacy you should
be so lucky to catch a
pigeon people don't realize when we say
when you're eating all your bunker food
that's what me and ryan are going to be
eating in new york city
we're going to be literally being like
let's find as a pigeon
i wish we bought some of those bunker
supplies
feasting on that sweet sweet
compacted granola
rice and beans
yeah just dry just rice and beans
you got the trinidad so we're going to
we're going to be sitting there a bunker
and yo yo we got chili powder and
paprika and we're going to be sitting
there and we're going to be you know
dancing and like yeah you know eating
rice and beans and you guys are going to
be munching on rat and you're going to
be like tim was right the whole time
our hair is going to be falling out from
the radiation speaking russian and
chinese and mix
russians this situation you can plant
dry beans from the grocery store i never
thoroughly thought that through but
that's awesome you could eat them or
plant them we just now you're just
rubbing it in yeah so now you have a
garden in your face
we use an endless supply of beans we got
a lot of beans we can eat danny's uh
crypto portfolio yeah that's gonna be
very useful in the end of times it's
crazy to think uh
you know if you go to certain higher end
restaurants they're often out of things
because they're hard to come by and
we've we've uh
every time i go there and ask for a hot
dog they're always out of it well
there's a there's a steakhouse nearby
and it's like
they were out of certain stake they're
like oh i don't have this meat one of
that meat it's hard to get it's really
expensive the prices are going up you
can't afford it but we're so we're so
luxurious in the united states that we
don't even think twice about going into
a local diner and saying for breakfast i
want like a sirloin top sirloin with
scrambled eggs and they're like yup no
problem and there are countries where
you're like getting protein is unheard
of yeah so it's just so
like americans totally that's like a one
you get that for ten bucks yeah and
that's why they keep saying you'll owe
nothing and you'll be happy because
they're like time to eat some bugs dude
and for me well i mean for most people
they do own nothing so that won't change
very much but i mean
there's an idea of you know 15 years ago
people used to own houses you know
people don't really own houses anymore
but this is because we've been taken
over by oligarchs no for real you know
uh so i i talk about wealth inequality
every so often because i think it's a
big problem and there's you know it's a
very common trope on the right where
it's like
relatively dismissive of it's not an
issue it doesn't come up as often yeah
but when you have a small handful of
ultra wealthy elites what they do is
like almost every time they buy up as
much property as they can because
property is mandatory well that's
happening now yeah exactly so when i
visited ukraine we saw this the new rush
i was looking at lofts in ukraine in
like 2013 and the prices were comparable
to like a house in in america and i
asked my ukrainian friend how is that
possible and she was like it's a bunch
of billionaire oligarchs who own their
own everything and they they have to
park their money just all over the world
and so they trade amongst each other but
but i was told but the rent is only like
50 bucks a month yeah and i'm like so
it's a three they take hits on them no
not really it's like
the the building should happen well they
just want to own the asset they don't
really care about the uh and i'm just
saying that well that's what i meant by
and
only other oligarchs can buy it so they
just talk amongst themselves like oh
yeah it's three and you want it okay
fine and it's and then foreign investors
that's the other thing too the oligarchs
know we'll put the price comparable to
the west because westerners who want to
get property in here we have to pay it
we own it all stars yeah that's
happening now with these companies
buying up i mean new york city houses
has tons of like some of the most
expensive properties are owned by
russian oligarchs wow
yeah there's a lot there's like i've
been seeing stuff where a bunch of these
places are going up for sale because you
know like roman abramovich he's like one
of the big ones and he's selling he owns
chelsea
he's been like the big owner and he's
like i have to sell it he's selling
chelsea because of this whole war wow
he's just like i have to get rid of it i
can't keep anything who can buy it oh
someone will buy it oh blackrock big
farm blackrock will take out a 100
billion dollar loan and then buy oh no
there'll be a lineup to buy that
there's no shortage of american
billionaires like
i don't get it how a company can take
out a billion billion dollar loan of
funny money and then just own now the
property's theirs because the funny
money said so like i don't believe the
funny money what do you mean like they
take out federal reserve loans which is
just basically fiat fake money it's
faith based money and then they buy they
can take part assets they they use
federal reserve i don't think they take
it directly from the they think from a
bank that took it from the fed
yeah they take it they don't take it at
zero percent i don't know no background
no no not at zero percent but but ian
that's how banking works
immediately this is how banking works
it's crazy when i swipe my credit card
the money just blinks into existence and
then i got nuts and these big companies
have so much assets to take loans out on
that they can take huge loans out and
then buy the assets and sell them back
next year for double the price i mean i
mean all of this is just based on the
fact that you know the us
you can only do this in america yeah
it's funny money it's the federal fiat
currency so how and they know it what
yeah well it's i mean like look you can
take uh you guys had your cash out
earlier like you can take that cash and
go spend that in any city in the world
pretty much other than the ones like
north korea where it's illegal or
whatever you can't do that with any
other currency right right like you go
anywhere on this planet and say here's a
five dollar american bill they go yeah
that's as good as anything
you're saying i can't go
you know
pay my tab in london with an ethiopian
frank go try and pay with a 20 canadian
bill and just the look they're going to
give so you're right so here's what
happens because i've been in american
money like i've traveled to maybe like
35 to 40 countries and i've asked this a
lot and the response i usually get like
when i go to morocco and i'm like will
you take us dollars they'll go
okay i guess
because they gotta go exchange it but
they're like
fine you know i'll take it you go you do
the opposite you get like you know a
boulevard fuerte from venezuela in your
garbage bag and you bring to a dunkin
donuts and you slam 300 pounds of cash
to buy one donut and they're like sir
get out of here what are you doing we're
calling the cops they won't it's just
toilet paper to them depends on where
yeah
yeah you're not gonna bro when i came
back from venezuela we had we had big
garbage bags of cash and so did you
really bring them we didn't bring the
full garbage bags but we had massive
stacks take him the strip club no no we
just i i turned the cash in it was go go
usher style yo check usher bucks no you
bring the gun with the other gun with
the venezuela they give us petty cash
when you're working for vice to spend on
day-to-day stuff
sure so we arrive in venezuela i'm like
how do we do it they're like you can't
it's illegal you can't do the official
exchange rate was like one dollar was
seven but they were like that's insane
because it's actually like 70. so a guy
smuggled in 70 you need 70 bills per
dollar yeah something like that so we
had
garbage bags
filled with money and we'd have to pull
out huge stacks and literally pay at a
restaurant like
nuts like yeah it's crazy in that
hyperinflationary environment too
because those people there's no such
thing as savings it's like you have to
spend the money instantly it's has
happened the moment you get it that's
why you gotta have it on swords yeah
yeah well but honestly but the moment
because tomorrow that loaf of bread is
like have you five stacks of money
instead of four stacks have you guys
been watching sword futures
yeah
through the roof like four or five
swords thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you